We don't want to solve for x or y in the second equation, since we would need to
move the terms around and divide by a coefficient in front of the variable. For
example, if we try to solve for x, we would have to subtract 3y from both sides
first, and then, divide every term by 5. That's kind of messy. A similar process
happens if we try and solve for y, so these two are out. If we try to solve for
x in this first equation we have to divide each term by 2, this would leave me
with x is equal to 2 minus 1 half y. Remember, there's a 1 as a coefficient in
front of the y, so this is really negative 1 half times y. I prefer to avoid
working with fraction in my substitution process, so this x isn't necessarily
the best choice. If I try and solve for y, I could add y to both sides, then,
rewriting my problem up here, I could subtract 2x from both sides and I would
get y is equal to negative 2x plus 4. Because I have integer coefficients like
negative 2 and 4, it's easier to work with this in a substitution. If you want
to solve for x and work with a fraction in your substitution, that's okay.
Choose the method that you feel most comfortable doing.